and he goes these [__] just
PayPal reversed the payment on me Char
charge backed after he's already doing
the videos charge back on him after he's
done on the deposit or the whole thing
crazy I was pissed bro I was so heated I
like couldn't believe it um cuz I was
like dude why would you not like try to
work someone out with me you know I was
like [__] it bro and I I went to their
like website and I realized they didn't
have the dot of their brand and I'm not
going to say it but I bought it and I
made it redirect to my
[__] and then
um if you want to buy it back I want the
charge back money plus what I paid for
it otherwise I'm just going to keep it I
lease that [__] Bro Finance you can
Finance it bro it's like $100 a month 0%
interest I can cancel it whenever I want
more
disrespectful told you get